[Music]
cleveland browns trying to continue a
dramatic turnaround from owen 16 in 2017
seven eight and one in 2018 we're gonna
take a closer look at the browns
offseason as part of an ongoing series
two teams per day today the browns and
the chargers and the browns look the bar
is extremely high chris it's higher than
it's ever been since the browns returned
to the nfl in 1999
and to their credit they're not standing
pat they have been aggressive they have
gone out and made moves adding otto
beckham jr adding kareem hunt olivier
vernon sheldon richardson having a draft
that even without a first round pick
because the first round pick became odo
beckham jr not a bad draft for the
browns addressing some areas of need
making some areas like corner stronger
with greedy williams sliding down to
them in round two pick number 46. look i
i'm i'm happy with what the browns have
done this off season but it only raises
the expectations the browns are gonna
make it to the postseason for the first
time since 2002. yeah it does i mean hey
with the star power they have the way
they ended last year you get odell
beckham jr on your football team you add
a sheldon richardson on the defensive
side of the ball with olivier vernon
like you said and yeah
the the public the media we're gonna
expect a lot from you i mean we see
greatness in a lot of these football
players so you know hey i'll say this
exactly what freddie kitchen says
whoopty hell with all these football
players they got on the roster right now
they do it's a bunch of individuals who
are building you know their techniques
and becoming better players so at one
point they can become one big cohesive
unit
as a football team altogether but hey on
paper come on this team is it's it's got
a lot of things to be extremely excited
about i don't know if there's any really
glaring weaknesses other than maybe you
like a little more depth or proven
commodities on the offensive line but
the starting five on the offensive line
okay it's up there it's in the top ten
in football i get on the defensive line
and when you go through you know some of
the guys they got on the list there
miles garrett olivier vernon sheldon
richardson larry ogunjobi you go whoa
you know just that face value that's
about as good as they get you talk about
two corners on the outside they had the
best cover corner in in the draft fall
to them in the second round and my man
thanos john dorsey trades up because he
goes holy crap this guy's still on the
board in the middle of the second i'm
gonna go get him who gives a damn about
tackling with the corner let's not make
that the basis of a guy falling 25 spots
so i looked at that and went wow denzel
ward now with a greedy williams hey
safety they got to figure out how they
want to balance it there mike but when
you look at them as a whole it's really
about yeah their ability i think to
learn how to win football games which
you and i have talked about the players
and the coaches learning you know what
what game plans on a weekly basis uh fit
their team and what gives them the best
chances to succeed but i don't look at
this roster in any shape way or form and
go oh you know they really have an issue
here in this one area this will be a
tough matchup for them they should be
able to match up with anybody in
football uh with the with the team that
uh thanos aka john dorsey has created
you know every team will say the goal is
to win the super bowl we get that we'll
stipulate that every team wants to win
the super bowl but there are still
degrees of success there is the question
of whether or not the team met the basic
expectations for the browns what does it
take to meet whatever the expectations
are how far do they have to go for you
to say that's a good season they
fulfilled their potential um
i don't want to say wild card but i'd
like to see them uh you know i you know
what i would say to fulfill the
potential i would say they are going to
be a playoff football team to fulfill it
yeah i am going to say that you know do
i totally expect when i sit here and
just you know if you made me bet money
today and said do the browns make the
playoffs or not i'm gonna bet yes they
are i don't know if they're gonna win
the afc north i think i'm still probably
gonna pick the pittsburgh steelers but i
think the browns are too talented they
got guys that are not afraid of the big
moments they got a quarterback who was a
fierce leader extremely talented i mean
answered any questions we had last year
about size moxie whatever it is the
talents through the roof so i just look
at it as a whole and go yeah i think
this is a team that should be in the
playoffs i don't know if they're going
to be you know 12 and four or anything
like that but a nine and seven ten and
six type football team that gets in at
the end of the day
i think to fulfill the expectations that
have been created by them and they've
embraced by loading up the cannon with
even more great players yeah i think
they have to make it to the round of
eight they have to make it to the
division around whether it's wild card
and win or get a buy which i think will
be very hard to do but if they would
finish
at that division around or higher they
fulfilled their expectations and these
expectations have been created by last
year's 7-8-1 record and by the moves
they're making the buzz they're building
and now we'll see if they can get it
done if they don't chris it's all going
to come back to the head coach freddie
kitchens that's why he's the one who
says whoop the hell because he knows
it's his fault if it doesn't go where it
needs to go yeah yeah but i mean so you
but playoffs aren't good enough you
think they gotta win one to make it all
fulfilled and feel better final eight
are you not listening to me i heard
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports